هاي الصوره ما وصلت لما بعثين الامميين
يعني مبعوث رايح مبعوث جاي على ليبيا هاي
الصوره ما وصلت لهم حتى ينقلوا هذا لمجلس
الامن بحيث يتدخل
بنحس انه في حلقه مفقوده
ن يحتقدوا ان الموضوع موضوع ليبي هو
الموضوع مش موضوع ليبي هي ليبيا اصلا
مشكله دوليه منذ البدايه لم تكون مشكله
جديده ما اصير عجيبه ليبي الي انا الدول
حلت مشاكلها وانطلقت اصلا الحمد لله حلت
مشاكرها اا نفتخر الان بالعام اللي قائم
في مصر في السعوديه من طريقين ما شاء الله
وفي الخليل
المشروعات محترمه زي مشروع نيوم اللي
متوليه همم ولي العهد همم محمد بن سلمان
يعني في العالم منطلق خالق تنميه وينطلقه
واحنا اليوم نفتخر ان همم اخوتنا في قطر
متبنين همم كاس العالم كله والعالم كلها
يستقي في في بلد عربي اسلامي نحن نريد
ننطق يعني ليبيا دوله مهمه ساده منتهى في
في شمال افريقيا ليبيا ممكن تكون مفتاح
الحل لتنميه وتطوير منطقه شمال افريقيا
وممكن تكون هي جسر العبور للتجاره الدوليه
بين قاره اوروبا وفي قاره افريقيا احنا لا
نفكر ونحنا الحمد لله
الان موجود خطوطا اخذ ماشي